[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue à l'émission
allons-nous l'émission au sein de sa
découverte ensemble vous allez parler
alors allons-nous
[Musique]
au milieu dans la forêt de Bellou et ben
nous là c'est nous ça a fait nos centres
le sentier du trou de fer poils nous
aller jusqu'au belvédère et ben nous
sentir trou de fer allons-nous quand
vous étiez coincé en France
[Musique]
déconnait ah la la paradis pour nous
rester
bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur
comment ça va ça va et vous ça va très
bien alors là vous montez moi je sens
vous venez d'où comme ça
ah c'est pas loin c'est pas loin c'est
un ami 1h15 à peu près alors 1h15
aller-retour non Calais il y a à peu
près 2h30 3h
pour faire l'aller-retour d'accord le
sentier il est un peu beau au départ
d'accord après il est bien pour être
câble OK et le trou de fer la vue était
bien dégagé et on a pu bien profiter de
la vue et c'était super sympa et une
famille peut venir faire cette randonnée
peut venir faire sur on a vu on a croisé
des familles et des petits enfants et
tout ça et sans souci d'accord et du
coup je vois un accent et de la Réunion
non de Montpellier nous après on va
faire ma fête on va faire on va la
silence ok faire Piton des Neiges mais
ça va être trop court au niveau du temps
ok l'hélicoptère et pas mal bon ben
super mais moi je risque de faire
donc c'est tout droit et puis ici nana
la reine des Tamarins il paraît que la
reine des Tamara n'a plus de 300 ans
trop de fer
arrive bonjour monsieur comment
allez-vous ben ça va bien au même ça va
dis-moi
d'accord
ça fait 10 ans 10 ans ok ah bah tiens on
parle moins de PMI comment il se passe
justement comme ça dans la forêt la
chasse ça démarre du 15 février au 15
avril c'est des mois de chasse on
cherche des jours d'accord le samedi
dimanche et mercredi d'accord de 6h et
18h OK et qui sera la moto justement
c'est les anciens quoi ah c'est
tradition alors du coup ouais voilà
c'est la tradition et du coup avant on
passait pas le PMI quoi d'accord ça
c'était la coutume ok j'ai dû vu avec le
braconnage
on est obligé de passer le PMU être dans
les règles et que ça oui j'aime qu'on
vient Chaston c'est où
le carré aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il trouve
bon pétanque dans la forêt non pas
beaucoup beaucoup ça diminue ça diminue
d'accord moi ce que je souhaite il faut
qu'il ferme la chasse pendant un an deux
ans à cause pour avoir une bonne
reproduction en fait
on se retrouve beaucoup des petites
encore des femelles tonnes qui sont
pleines et bon maintenant
allez dans sac à dos voilà
ok
bon en tout cas merci bien
comment ça va mais ça va aussi merci
de voir un tronçon de santé à Monsieur
le sentier trop de fer l'onfa est
réalisé un premier tronçon la 2 ans et
on a réceptionné l'année dernière le
deuxième tronçon on est sur une forêt
que les 13 humide on a de la pluie toute
l'année donc oui toute l'année n'a de la
pluie et donc le sentier il est souvent
boueux et ce claque là j'ai plus
confortable on va se place là j'ai payé
aux randonneurs de marcher de façon plus
confortable et aussi il y a un élément
et un intérêt aussi à mettre en place
c'est que il évite en fait de permettre
de protéger la forêt et évite aux
randonneurs un petit peu de quitter le
sentier pour aller marcher sur les
déserts et abîmer les abîmer les plantes
c'est ça va pas la patelage c'est ça le
platelage en bois l'effet en madrier de
bois que les poser sur des cales pareil
en bois avec un grillage qui est
antidérapant
oui on peut passer par là il y a pas de
problème on aura un platelage et on aura
un sentier qui sera plus confortable
qu'avant bien sûr
mon pays
[Musique]
commente la même une respect pour mon
pays mais vraiment après depuis son lit
au bout de la terre dans le Paradis et
ben voilà j'arrive au belvédère oulala
un gros brouillard malheureusement ah
ben ça tombe bien des gens qui sont en
train de regarder quelque chose bonjour
madame bonjour vous allez bien allez
bonjour
alors dites-moi qu'est-ce que vous êtes
en train de regarder
les nuages non le trou de le trou de fer
alors normalement il est pas là
on nous a dit que c'était très beau mais
bon et quand vous arrivez là et que vous
voyez c'est on peut rien voir alors
est-ce que c'est frustrant ou pas ben
non parce que la balade enfin un petit
peu mais la balade est jolie la balade
dans la forêt est jolie c'est le risque
à la Réunion d'arriver à des points de
vue et
voilà c'est un coup de chance ou alors
il faut se lever très tôt voilà bonne
vacances à vous merci beaucoup
de fesse du cascades les plus haute de
France avec plus de 725 mètres de
hauteur ok la Réunion on en a gagné
et tout ça rendez vous à la prochaine
épisode de l'émission de nous nous sera
du côté du volcan sur les sorties
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]